your boy got with the San Diego Chapter
yesterday drove yesterday morning oh
that's right I heard I heard it was a
dicey road dude I heard it was John so
so Papa's been biking since the
quarantine start grew up on mount bike
daycare was a mountain bike I did not
okay yeah okay so you got some
experience they took you on some they
took you on some [ __ ] on it
bottom left winch in the yellow bike
that's uh that's a heckler Santa Cruz e
bike they sent it to me to try out there
that's your brother gray bike is that
you that's me was your brother
nope why would my brother be okay I
don't know um but I went with my boy
Chris Byers who she's been around for a
while he's rep for Santa Cruz he's a rep
for royal bike gear those are his trails
well these trails were built for you two
guys named bivariate it's basically like
it'd be like Michael Jordan Michael
joining a doubles barked I like Michael
Jordan build a basketball court to make
it as difficult it's possible so this
guy lives in the neighborhood across the
street but he built these trails for
competitive mountain bike riding we boy
I'm not in that Lane yet I'm not sure
I'm trying to get I'm trying to figure
it out yeah those he bikes the the
heckler Santacruz bikes ridiculous it's
ridiculous bike now they want you or
theater come with you guys our show like
you I don't know I say I was out of my
comfort zone yeah I'm talking you know
the there was professional riders on
there and showman doing these strikes on
stuff he's the one the trails that it's
long are your like 2025 miles and it's a
lot of climbing they go down but it's
not these there's no room for error on
these because the trail is about all yay
wide and there's jagged rocks and and
huge drop-offs with a jump and there's
Ram and then and then the tricky thing
is the corners are the sharpest it is
built for competition so the so these
guys can these pros can get ready for
the tour no I'm not there yet no no but
this guy never be there by the way
that's okay yeah well that's not my
thing
no that's not what that's not the
mountain bike I do but this guy Chris
who's a beast on it was right shall we
go up in the up I'm it I can tell I'm
like all right and there's all these
trails and I go down pretty gnarly just
yeah man
he's yeah and then okay so we're going
and he's great chris is the [ __ ] best
and he jumps off does it trick me yeah
that's it hey man we're doing tricks now
well here's the thing here's the thing
papa
here's the thing your boy crashed oh I
don't know five times oh you did well
there's only one way down and I get a go
X game on this [ __ ] yeah so what I was
doing yeah yeah I'm not used to it you
got to commit we have to commit and fly
off the edge Brian
well I'm 37 and I'm not I'm not there
mentally I'm out there I don't know so
the first one I don't commit I kind of
half-ass it when I say I didn't shoot
off I mean I went full yeah fell down
all the way down by cliff I'm not a big
deal [ __ ] the entire Santa Cruz I
apologize [ __ ] the bike completely up
you've been handlebars the fact that big
quarts of scratches all over the thing
and you know rocks rocks they're not
forgiving they're not jagged rocks
aren't forgiving well but this other
thing I worry about because when I do
roll into the the bushes and the VD is
name their sons are outside which I was
warned about so Piper's Viper
I was so scared so when I say I was
stressed I mean I'm talking white
knuckle down thing but then but then he
goes we get done that I go of the rest
trails like this he was yeah sex was
actually hard I don't wanna say anything
so we get up and then we're going down
but then I go hey I I didn't want to I
want to seem cool because you know and I
just went hey man I usually I don't like
this competitive stuff I'm not used to
man so I get be honest I mean I did some
of those jumps I don't know what I'm
doing he goes don't you isn't this what
you do no I don't do this that I don't
do like this competitive stuff he goes
oh [ __ ] howling Ben Rango about three
months he goes oh oh yeah no I'll help
you man so then I was like I'll follow
your lead he's like here's the thing man
I know he's scary you got to commit I
was like alright tell me what to do I'll
commitment and so by the end of it your
boy was [ __ ] I mean I'm jumping off
cliff
still crash I'm a jumping off yeah
that's not find your mom
not for me well that's where we were
easy Oh Jim I say I caught your boycott
here what the [ __ ] is that oh that's not
for me the trail dude that's the trail
and then you gotta just go over that
come on gnar six pounds so nan and I'm
on this ebike and I would have been I
would have been I would have no would've
been a delay there so those guys are
flying by me I went but here's my thing
I got complete on my comfort zone at a
great time that bikes a [ __ ] beast
Chris is amazing he gave me all these
tips I learned so much in those three
hours yeah I learned so far you can see
how it become addictive when you can
navigate that stuff but not I need to
see that
that's my mount there you go that's what
I do let's see those white trails I'll
do that with you jump I'll get with you
well that's what I do every day then
there's some dicey parts sure but it's
not all dice now the turns I'm not I'm
not Germany McGrath I'm not I'm not
ready for this dude but by the end of it
we got the hang of it it was a lot of
fun as girls a complete diamond piecing
just saw her um
cute family yeah now what does he do he
is the owner of a company no he's a rep
for all these companies
he's like Heathrow when they have like
the big like world trials and stuff he
goes to those Wow he's uh yeah he's a
mechanic he does all the stuff right
great dude great dude yeah I am in the
city of chapters very fond of now that's
not San Diego I won't there's nothing
it's called oh there we are
yes a lot that's a lot is that who's
that that you knows him that's a lot and
you don't look big there you look you
look rather small
that's not forgiving train so Vipers and
sharp rocks not my thing for me not my
thing not where I want to fall well have
another seven and she does the trick so
there's that well she's grown up doing
it yeah also she doesn't fall as hard
she's also very good yeah
it was it was like such a learning
experience when I got to my car I was so
I go wait longer in my own I was so
tired though because they were so taxing
am I just my I've so Ted's dude if you
had perished I would have probably had
to have taken over the thick point by
Club yes and I would have viciously did
a little helmet it's awesome so cute Wow
he didn't know that you'd only done it
for three months and really not three
months right even less than that problem
maybe three months is it three months
well how long because I started the day
one two o'clock I had a bike three
months every day yeah yeah he don't
there it is so that's see I'm not I'm
not there it's just about my I was so
stressed shot - Chris Chris Byers
it's a Chris Byers 85 great bike though
phenomenal bike amazing and he in his
thing was he goes you as what you're
doing is he is your are you a control
freak is your trying to control
everything let the bike do its job
because when you're when you're flying
and going down these you gotta let the
bike do his job just hang on to it relax
sit back like you got Laureles the all
the way and let the bike these shocks
all this stuff all these things that
this bike makes the bike let it do its
job this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]